une trêve hivernale qui se prolonge pour
le centre aquatique du lac les bassins
resteront fermés au public jusqu'au 21
janvier
en cause les travaux entamés il y a dix
jours et qui prévoit notamment de
renforcer la sécurité et l'hygiène des
sanitaires avec l'installation d'un
nouveau sol
razik est légèrement légèrement granit
et donc il va empêcher le
la glissade donc il sera plus sécure
aujourd'hui en avait au niveau des
niveaux du carrelage sur la partie
douche ici donc le sol et l'ensemble des
murs va être revêtue alors qu'en fait au
parti au niveau de la des vestiaires ça
sera uniquement le sol
le chantier permettra également de
remplacer la totalité des éclairages
dons et en dehors des bassins pour un
système plus économique
l'accès à la piscine est aussi repensé
avec une nouvelle billetterie
enfin les casiers sont remplacés les
monnayeurs sont abandonnés pour plus de
simplicité on va remettre des portes des
casiers plus traditionnelles qui en fait
avec uniquement le paiement fin ce sera
le la mise d'une pièce pour avoir la
caution
les personnes récupéreront ensuite leur
leur leur pièce quand il contient
destroy et quasi vides il y aura une clé
donc en fait c'est un système tout à
fait classique coût total des travaux
430 mille euros ouvert il ya quinze ans
le centre aquatique et fréquenté tous
les ans en moyenne par plus de cent
mille personnes